hey youtubers is Charlie so ages of
shield video as requested there are some
grade-a creepy stuff happening on shield
right now
so this is gonna be a theory video
involving the spider-man comics as well
as some of the stuff that's been
happening in the movies and the TV shows
I'll be doing a lot more bonus
easter-egg comic book videos during the
break that we're getting ready for so be
sure to subscribe to get everything make
sure you click the bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out so I'm gonna play
these clips from agents of shield just
to give you a little bit of context and
then explain what's going on shield
wants to see what I'm creating I'll show
them all we need the big guns on this
one and yo-yo Daisy andreas with the
biggest guns we have
there's something in that building
everyone needs to see I am becoming a
god you better be because the devil is
coming for you
like playing with fire let's play all
cards on the table 8 isn't Android
she's what did you just say an Android
had me fooled too that's who okay
I mean forget about the fact that I was
mildly attracted to her that totally
goes against the sokovia course doesn't
anyone remember Ultron was this
Radcliffe's doing sir we really don't
have much time the point is a good
director needs to know what assets he
has at his disposal and in this case I
think ADA could be an asset a risky one
but it's your call agent may go to dr.
Radcliffe slab and get ADA I want to run
this mission will dismantle her
afterwards what about my assault team
you got the green light book Olsen keep
Daisy out of sight so in Doctor Strange
they explained that they harness the
energy from other dimensions to use
their magic that's where their power
comes from we learned that you can also
harness energy from the Dark Dimension
to gain even more power at the cost of
your soul the power you gain through the
dark hold is also the same deal you
start reading through the pages you gain
knowledge you give up your soul so it's
all heading in that direction
but right now in the comics there's
actually a really interesting dark hold
story going on in the carnage solo title
Cletus Kasady learned about a prophecy
in the dark hold that describes him and
he feels like it's a prophecy that he's
meant to set cthe on free he's the
writer of the dark holt he's a class-one
demon one of the elder gods of the
Marvel Universe so basically like the
worst possible thing that could happen
carnage is meant to unleash it on the
Marvel Universe so something similar is
probably also happening on agents of
shield but we're at the mid-season
finale so it's a little early for
somebody that big to manifest that's
like the kind of thing you'd save for a
serious finale
even the Doctor Strange movie only
lightly touched on the
dormammu they didn't over explain it you
just learned that he's the conqueror of
dimensions he just goes from reality to
reality making everything that exists
his so on shield Eli Morrow is calling
himself a God just because he's infused
with this power he can seemingly create
matter out of nothingness but really he
just become a conduit for this other
dimension that he's pulling energy from
in the theory is is that because of what
happens to everyone that tries to use
the dark hold there is some power that
will try to manifest in our reality now
it looks like he's kind of building a
gateway to they just did that in the
recent episode you saw like a version of
Marvel's hell that's usually Mephisto
but there are hell lords so there are a
number of people that could poke back
out from the darkness you have people
like satanic you even have Dormammu
although I don't think that the TV show
would do Dormammu just because of the
links the Doctor Strange had to go to
even contact him I feel like Dormammu is
gonna stay a movie villain for now but
they might reference him on the TV show
the dark hold itself is mostly connected
to cthe on the person that wrote it but
he's also known as the demon of the dark
hold the great shadow so if you're big
joss whedon fan and you're waiting for
like some mystery giant terrible figure
to manifest from a dark portal it would
be the demon of the dark hold but on the
flip side of this let's talk about the
Ultron part of this
she's not at her name ah Hayden what
else rhymes with you
ada is making herself a brain which
looks a lot like the AI consciousness
from Avengers age of Ultron just the way
they made that look with the CG so I
don't think that she's actually going to
become Ultron but she's making herself a
brain to enhance her power to enable her
to fully take advantage of what the
Darkhold
offers so the likely scenario in that
case is a very similar Ultron situation
where she just totally does not buy in
to what all the humans want like she
feels like she knows better
Ultron thought of the humans is a cancer
on the earth so he wanted to get rid of
them but like the title of the last
episode deals with our devil's ADA even
if she does gain this super Darkhold
brain will be the only person who could
fight Eli Morrow so you send a God to
fight a god she is slowly becoming a God
in her own right which we've learned
from all Marvel movies and comics always
ends terribly for everyone but just like
Dormammu and Doctor Strange carnage in
the demon of the dark holes in the
comics Eli Morrow looks like he's going
to unleash chaos on the world if he's
successful the funny thing in the comics
is is the teaser for like the next
episode of agents of shield is the exact
same carnage is beginning to unleash
cthe on just as eli Morrow's getting
ready to activate his mystery box to
hell so let me know what you guys think
is going on do you think this is gonna
be like the comics Eli Morrow will
unleash the demon of the dark hold or
they'll use some other character on the
TV show the only thing that stops people
short from talking about people like
Mephisto or Dormammu on the TV shows is
you know like what can they do in the
movies what does Marvel have the rights
to the interesting difference between
Marvel's TV shows in its movies is that
the rights are a little bit different so
there are like movie rights for things
then there are television rights so if
they couldn't do a character in the
movies just because another studio has
the rights that doesn't mean that they
couldn't do that character on television
but it gets a little messy when you talk
about that so I have a feeling that what
shield will actually do is they'll find
some clever workaround where they'll be
like a dark persona but he won't
actually manifest and look like somebody
from the comics because like the demon
of the dark holed looks kind of like
this
Cthulhu like
figure you know tentacles on his head
and they kind of did that last season
with high structure then march down to
announce to the shield agents that I
finally succeeded in defeating the great
enemies a day as one
money to remain concealed shadow so I
don't think they're gonna recycle that
look usually characters that are this
powerful like Dormammu are scarier when
you don't give them a full physical form
that's kind of the reason why they did
that in Doctor Strange they just
explained that the only reason he would
take physical form was for the benefit
of Doctor Strange when he came to
approach him other wise beings like
Dormammu can exist in whatever state
they want they could be like a scary
glow cloud it's just that the glow
clouds are kind of boring to watch in a
big hundred and fifty million dollar
movie but the winner finale for agents
of shield is happening next week so I'll
be doing a video for that they're also
doing the winter finales for the DC TV
shows too so let me know what kind of
bonus videos you guys want me to do
during the mid-season break there'll be
a lot of comic book stuff let me know if
you want me to finish that carnage
Darkhold story is actually pretty cool
the artwork is great and it's written by
Gerry Conway who created a lot of the
comic book characters that they use on
the DC TV shows right now so just funny
to see like such a big comic book writer
that's done so much DC work do like a
really cool Marvel story so next video
will be the new guardians of the galaxy
trailer that'll post tonight get hype
it's gonna be awesome while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my breakdown of the last guardians
trailer and you can click here for my
breakdown of the spider-man footage they
showed off yesterday thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you